vous venez sauvez mon âme c'est votre
anniversaire
ouais la folle soirée ne fait que
commencer et se nomme calomnie
nous avons remonté s'aligner sur cinq
siècles jusqu'au pré doter la salle
caloone aux yeux des gens pour autant
que cela leur importe vous n'existez
plus c'est quoi cet endroit
ceci est votre seconde chance
qu'est ce que vous voulez votre passé
vous allez en paix dans l'animus ce que
vous allez voir
entonne les ressentir sont les souvenirs
de votre ancêtre qui est mort depuis 500
ans attendait les bienvenus dans
l'inquisition espagnole
ce que j'ai vu le temps on m'aurait dit
à m
c'était bien réel
observent ils attendent de voir qui tue
la force
je vous crois promis à de grandes choses
voyant ça
nous agissons dans l'ombre à vous pour
servir la lumière
nous sommes déjà sa femme
ça commence à me plaire
je suis jeune hier soir à 18 heures vous
avez été exécutés et déclaré moi vous
n'existez plus
c'est quoi cette prison ce n'est pas une
prison vous allez entrer dans l'animus
ce que vous allez voir entendre et
ressentir sans les souvenirs de votre
ancêtre qui est mort depuis 500 ans
voulez vous à moi votre passé
bienvenue dans l'inquisition espagnole
belga
il y a
isabelle
nous agissons dans l'andra pour servir
la lumière nous sommes des assassins